alors est ce que tu peux me dire qu'ils
sur le bief nom est michael mcdonough
n'ont pas su en profiter pour le frais
de leurs aînés bravo
regardez bien ce billet de cinq dollars
il sera parmi les derniers à représenter
le premier premier ministre canadien
français après avoir retiré john et mec
d'un ordre pour le remplacer par la
militante viola desmond voilà que la
banque du canada lance une consultation
pour changer le visage du 5 $ pour
donner l'occasion aux canadiens de nous
proposer qu'ils aimeraient voir sur le
billet jusqu'au 11 mars les citoyens
canadiens sont invités à inscrire sur le
site de la banque du canada le nom d'une
personnalité canadienne
elle doit être décédé depuis 25 ans ne
pas être fictive et avoir oeuvré pour
tous les canadiens
marguerite bourgeoys tim hortons louis
riel depuis le 29 janvier des centaines
de noms ont été proposés par plus de
vingt mille personnes
le portrait de la communauté chrétienne
aujourd'hui pas le même non plus pour
cet historien il est important de
renouveler les symboles pour qu'ils
représentent des valeurs contemporaines
certains égards on peut se demander
qu'est ce que représente lauriers pour
les gens aujourd'hui moins controversé
que johnny mac donald à qui l'on
attribue notamment la création des
pensionnats autochtones
wilfrid laurier est perçu comme un
politicien pragmatique et modéré qui
représente les valeurs de son époque
aujourd'hui on verrait sa politique
comme assez hostile au multiculturalisme
mais elle était inscrite dans les
pratiques de l'époque je fais référence
notamment à la fameuse taxe d'entrée qui
a été imposée sur les immigrés d'origine
chinoise
c'est une taxe qui est augmentée par le
riz par son administration en 1900 alors
été passé à 100 dollars et puis en 1903
est passé à 500 dollars par cette
démarche
la banque du canada souhaite mieux
représenter la diversité et les valeurs
canadiennes
à terme elles prévoient réintégrer les
premiers ministres lauriers et
mcdonald's sur les billets de 50 et 100
dollars
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal